If you want to see my theory about the secret
behind this mysterious machine at the end
of the trailer, then stick around to the end
of this video.
(Intro)
Anything I mentioned in my previous Happy
Death Day videos won't be in this video, so
if you don't know the meaning of these posters
and you want to relive the day you watched
those videos, then check out this playlist.
And obviously there will be spoilers for the
first movie.
In those videos on the original film, I mostly
focused on the decorations on this side of
the room.
But there were a couple notable things to
catch my eye on the other side, such as these
but I'll come back those later in the video.
First, I want to look at this poster.
It's the cover of a book called Pulse of Power.
I haven't read the book myself, but here's
a summary I found on Google books.
Destiny is always a choice!
Tia Stanton is not an ordinary woman.
Created from a mystical rite, she is birthed
into a world where chaos and organization
run side by side; where monster and man live
in unison but rarely with recognition of each
other.
Until the race begins -- a fight to gain access
to the pool of power lying beneath her hometown
of Greenwich, Connecticut.
It coincides with her twenty-fifth birthday
and her last chance to accept the full mantel
of this supernatural power.
There are a lot of parallels between the protagonist
Tia Stanton, and Tree Gelbman from Happy Death
Day.
They are both female protagonists with a supernatural
aspect in their respective stories.
Both have a major test of character that lands
on their birthday and both have the sole responsibility
of overcoming their circumstances.
Looking back to that shelf in Carter’s dorm
room, there is also a mini-basketball.
There is also a basketball hoop on the back
of their door which can be seen more clearly
in the first film.
Remember, Christopher Landon has been planning
this sequel all along, so foreshadowing the
fact that Carter and his roommate Ryan are
basketball fans may be related to the fact
that Happy Death Day 2U has a scene taking
place at their college's basketball game.
And in the basketball scene, we get a bit
more info about the branding of their college
team The Babies.
They are playing a team called the Tritons
and losing pretty badly.
Some of the team’s slogans seen in the stands
include Welcome to the Cradle, The Cradle
Will Rock, Babies Gonna Deliver, which, to
prevent any of you from ending up on the wooosh
subreddit, is a pun about babies being newborns
and newborns being found in the delivery room
at a hospital.
There's also a banner reading "Naptime for
Thurman".
I'm guessing Thurman is probably the star
player of the Tritons.
The one that interests me most though is this
one that says"Baby Gang".
Could this be a hint that there are multiple
killers?
We do see other shots in the trailer with
multiple baby masks, and even instances where
there are other baby masks in the room seeing
the violence happen to show that they are
possibly affiliated.
It's also interesting because if you remember
last year when I went into the Happy Death
Day maze at Halloween Horror nights, there
was a room with a bunch of those baby-mask
killers, something that wasn't really a scene
in the first movie, unlike everything else
we saw in that maze.
In addition to there possibly being multiple
killers who don the baby mask, it looks like
there will also be suspense about who the
actually killer is, and who is just wearing
the mask because they're a fan of the team.
I spotted Ryan in the background in the crowd
with Tree and Carter after the game.
He's also wearing black and it appears this
is shortly before they get chased by a baby-mask
with a black hoodie.
We don't have enough info for me to really
make any predictions, but I'm inclined to
add him to my list of suspects.
By the way, in this scene in the trailer where
Tree offers Ryan advice about being stuck
in the time loop, she mentions the following.
"I might be able to help with that.
I died 11 times."
But hold on.
She only died 10 times in Happy Death Day.
That means she's already back in the time-loop
before this conversation takes place.
To make matters more complicated, this isn't
the exact same day she re-lived before, because
in this timeline, there's also someone going
after Lori, the killer from the first movie.
And speaking of that first movie, there are
of course, a few callbacks like this knife
through the door during a kill, Tree's walk
of shame, a visit to the hospital ward and
this scene with Tree skydiving in her underwear
(possibly a reference to the time Tree goes
nude during the first one) just to mess with
people because she knows the day will reset.
On the skydiving plane, there is a poster
briefly seen towards the front of the aircraft
that has the words, like a leaf.
The quote is common cliche, and a metaphor
for helplessness, but in this case, may also
be a reference to a character from the TV
show Firefly whose catchphrase is, "I am a
leaf in the wind, watch how I soar," which
has a bit of a different meaning in the content
of skydiving obviously, but could be representative
of the themes of Happy Death Day, since trees
have leaves, and Tree is the name of the character
who is trying to take control and find the
better version of her life, as she says in
the trailer.
"But now I'm living the better version of
my life."
If you watched my Things You Missed in Happy
Death Day, one thing I talked about was how
the street signs used as decorations throughout
the movie were symbols of the flow of time,
and how the one-way sign seen at the end of
the film meant that now that Tree has broken
the curse she won't have to go back to the
beginning of that day anymore, time will only
flow in one direction.
In the trailer, we see that sign again, this
time through a mirror, meaning the only way
to go for her now is backwards in time in
order to solve the puzzle yet again and break
the curse.
This time, it seems like there's more to it
than just that and it has something to do
with this machine.
If we quickly rewind to the beginning of the
trailer, there are a couple of books on this
shelf on the topics of biochemistry and molecular
cloning, and in the trailer after firing up
this machine, Ryan can be seen briefly coming
face to face with himself.
Could this have something to do with the fact
that after each day is reset, Tree's body
is unharmed, but her memories of the previous
day are somehow transferred to the new body?
Will Happy Death Day 2U finally explain why
Tree is stuck in this loop in the first place?
If this trailer is any indication, we'll be
learning a lot more about the logistics of
the time travel in this universe.
Now when I gave the DeadTalk about Happy Death
Day 2U, I predicted that the new time loop
would take place on Valentine's Day and the
2U was a reference to those candy hearts.
We now know this not to be the case, however,
my new theory on “2U” is that it's a reference
to the passive aggressive language Tree and
her sorority use to communicate with each
other, as seen in the first movie.
*music*
Finally, there's one pretty creepy thing you
might have missed in the title animation,
the face of the killer's mask is reflected
in the knife.
This video was sponsored by the CZsWorld merch
store.
Right now we're having a holiday sale.
This month only, use code DEATHMAS for 10%
off any order.
If you're interested in Happy Death Day or
anything related to horror, make sure you
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.